>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT".
TIME FOR A CONFESSION OFF THE
BAT.
THERE WERE TIMES BACK IN THE
DARK AGES OF CABLE NEWS WHEN WE
WOULD MILK A SINGLE NEWS EVENT
FOR WEEKS.
IN SOME CASES AND WE'RE TALKING
TO YOU, O.J. SIMPSON FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS.
THERE WASN'T THAT MUCH GOING ON.
YOU COULDN'T AFFORD TO WASTE A
GOOD STORY.
THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM WE HAVE
THESE DAYS.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE'S TOO MUCH
GOING ON AND SOME OF IT IS
TERRIFYING.
IN JUST THE LAST WEEK, CHINA
SIGNED A $50 BILLION TRADE DEAL
WITH SAUDI ARABIA.
OUR OLD ALLY.
SIGNALLING AN END TO AMERICA'S
LONGEST PETRO EMPIRE.
THAT'S NOT A SMALL THING.
VLADIMIR PUTIN MEANWHILE THAT
RUNS RUSSIA THREATENED TO LAUNCH
A NUCLEAR WAR ON THE WEST.
WALL STREET BEGAN LAYING OFF
LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN IGNORE IN A BUSINESS THAT IT
IS TO PREDICT THE FUTURE OF THE
ECONOMY.
THE WEALTH OF THE AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD DROPPED TO THE LOWEST
LEVELS EVER RECORDED.
THE CDC TRIES TO RESURRECT FACE
MASKS THAT WILL HELP.
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED GOT ARRESTED.
THE MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS WHICH
RUN THE LARGEST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS SINCE THE
TRANS ATLANTIC TRADE ENDED NOW
OFFICIALLY HAVE CONTROL OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT'S BEEN A BUSY WEEK.
MORE HAPPENED IN THIS WEEK THAN
HAPPENED IN TWO FULL TERMS UNDER
BILL CLINTON.
IT'S A LOT.
IF YOU'RE RUNNING OUR COUNTRY,
YOU'D STAY UP EVERY NIGHT
FIGURING OUT HOW TO RESPOND.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
THIS AFTERNOON AS THE OLD GLOBAL
ORDER COLLAPSES TO BE REPLACED
BY GOD KNOWS WHAT, THE BIDEN
PEOPLE DECIDED TO HOLD A DRAG
EVENT AT THE WHITE HOUSE JUST IN
CASE YOU'RE WONDERING IF THOSE
COMPARISONS WERE OVERSTATED.
THEY'RE NOT.
THE OCCASION FOR THIS
CELEBRATION WAS THE OFFICIAL
SIGNING OF THE RESPECT FOR
MARRIAGE ACT.
WHICH THE WHITE HOUSE TELLS US
WILL CODIFY GAY MARRIAGE IN TO
LAW.
WAIT A MOMENT, YOU WONDER.
WASN'T GAY MARRIAGE LEGALIZED BY
THE SUPREME COURT WAY BACK UNDER
BARACK OBAMA?
WELL, YEAH.
BUT THEY HAVE LEGALIZED IT
AGAIN.
IT'S DOUBLE LEGAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
IT'S TIME TO HEAR FROM LADY
GAGA.
♪♪
>> Tucker: DANCE PARTY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE!
HOORAY.
WHAT'S BEEN LEGAL FOR YEARS IS
STILL LEGAL.
BREAK OUT THE WHITE CLAW.
CINDI LAUPER WAS THERE TO
CELEBRATE.
SHE'S 70 YEARS OLD THIS SPRING.
SHE'S LIVED IN THIS COUNTRY A
LONG TIME.
UNTIL TODAY, UNTIL THIS
AFTERNOON AT THE WHITE HOUSE
UNDER THE GAYS OF JOE BIDEN THE
GREAT, CINDI LAUPER INFORMED US
THAT AMERICANS WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO LOVE EACH OTHER.
UNTIL TODAY, LOVE WAS BANNED.
JOE BIDEN CHANGED THAT.
NOW WE'RE FREE TO LOVE.
WATCH THIS AND SEE IF YOU DON'T
CHOKE UP JUST A LITTLE.
>> OUR FAMILIES ARE VALIDATED.
BECAUSE WE'RE ALLOWED TO LOVE
WHO WE LOVE, WHICH SOUNDS ODD TO
SAY, BUT AMERICANS CAN NOW LOVE
WHO WE LOVE.
BLESS JOE BIDEN AND ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WORKED ON THIS FOR
ALLOWING PEOPLE NOT TO WORRY AND
THEIR CHILDREN NOT TO WORRY
ABOUT THEIR FUTURE.
>> Tucker: WAIT.
DIDN'T THAT HAPPEN TEN YEARS
AGO?
THAT TAPE IS FROM TODAY.
THE PARTY WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
THAT MEANS THAT SOMEWHERE OUR
NUCLEAR DISPOSAL FRIENDS, SAME
BRINTON IS SITTING APILE OF
STOLEN CLOTHES CURSING THE FACT
THAT AIRPORT SECURITY CAMERAS
ARE IN THE BAGGAGE CLAIM.
IF HE WASN'T CAUGHT, THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN CHRISTMAS FOR HIM.
HE COULD HAVE TRIED TO GET A NEW
HALTER TOP IN CINDI LAUPER'S
DRESS ROOM.
MARTY CUMMINGSS THAT A LONG
HISTORY OF UNFELTERED SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS.
F THE POLICE, CUMMINGS TWEETED
IN 2020.
YES, WE WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE AND ABOLISH ICE.
WE WON'T SETTLE FOR ANYTHING
LESS AND FIGHT FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE ANTIFA.
WELL, YEAH.
AND TO PROVE IT THIS YEAR,
CUMMINGS PROMOTED A-CAB COFFEE
USING THE SLOGAN OF ANTIFA.
SO HERE YOU HAVE AN ANTIFA
FRIENDLY DRAG QUEEN DRESSING UP
AS A WOMAN AND PROMOTING
VIOLENCE.
A PERFECT WHITE HOUSE GUEST.
AND CUMMINGS IS INTERESTS IN
CHILDREN THE WRONG WAY.
KIDS ARE OUT TO SINK AND SUCK TO
PERFORM FELACIO.
ANYBODY THAT DOESN'T THINK DRAG
IS FOR CHILDREN IS WRONG.
CUMMINGS POSTED THIS PICTURE
WITH A CHILD SAYING HE WANTS TO
PERFORM WITH US NEXT YEAR.
SO IF YOU THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO
ACCUSE PEOPLE OF BEING CREEPY
WITH KIDS, IT'S NOT THAT UNFAIR,
ACTUALLY.
KIND OF FAIR.
HERE'S CUMMINGS AT A TED TALK IN
2019.
>> I LEARNED HOW THE POWER OF A
20-SECOND VIDEO CAN CHANGE YOUR
LIFE.
HOW A 20-SECOND CLIP CAN CHANGE
YOUR ENTIRE WORLD VIEW.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪♪
>> THAT'S ME AND 2-YEAR-OLD
BRODY AT MY DRAG BRUNCH IN
NEW JERSEY.
SO A LOT OF TIMES FAMILIES COME
TO THE BRUNCH BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO GO TO A REGULAR DRAG
SHOW AT NIGHT.
THAT'S A TIME WHEN KIDS CAN
EXPERIENCE DRAG.
BECAUSE OF BABY SHARK, I CAME TO
THE BILL GRIM HOUSE AND DO A
SERIES OF KID SHOWS.
I WOULD ASK THE KIDS DURING
THESE SHOWS, I WOULD SAY WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO BE WHEN YOU GROW UP?
AND TO MY SURPRISE A LOT OF
THESE KIDS SAID THEY WANTED TO
BE A DRAG QUEEN.
>> Tucker: YEAH, A LOT OF KIDS
WANT TO BE A DRAG QUEEN.
THAT'S THE GUY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY.
NOT REALLY AN ANOMALY.
A MONTHS AGAINST, THEY IDENTIFY
DYLAN MULVANEY.
HE MET THE PRESIDENT.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
MULTIPLE THINGS, THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO DEGRADE THE COUNTRY,
TO MAKE IT INTO A JOKE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE STRIDING
THROUGH THE HALLWAYS THAT ONCE
WERE THE WORK AREA OF I DON'T
KNOW ABRAHAM LINCOLN, TEDDY
ROOSEVELT AND F.D.R.
THESE ARE SERIOUS MEN THAT
STAYED UP LATE EVERY NIGHT
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THE
COUNTRY BETTER.
AND NOW THERE'S THAT GUIDE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE THAT AND
CINDI LAUPER CELEBRATING GAY
MARRIAGE WHICH HAS BEEN LEGAL
SINCE THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
AGAIN, IT'S AN EFFORT TO DEGRADE
THE COUNTRY, BUT AS A POLITICAL
MATTER, IT'S A DISTRACTION.
OFFEND YOU SO MUCH OR MESMERIZE
YOU SO COMPLETELY THAT YOU
FORGET THAT THERE'S MULTIPLE
WORLD HISTORIC CRISES UNFOLDING
AT THE SAME TIME, SOME OF WHICH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAUSED.
NONE OF WHICH IT CAN SOLVE.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT TO DO
ABOUT THE COLLAPSE OF THE POST
WAR ORDER, WHICH IS ON DISPLAY
OR THE CONTINUING SLOW MOTION
COLLAPSE OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY, WHICH YOU FEEL.
BECAUSE YOUR POORER THAN YOU
WERE LAST YEAR AND THEY DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY TO YOU.
EVEN IF THEY CARED, THEY DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER.
HERE'S A DRAG SHOW.
WELCOME TO VYMAR.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
THE POINT IS, YOU LOSE ANY
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE
REAL THAT IS HAPPENING.
THIS IS A TACTIC.
IT'S NOT A NEW TACTIC, ACTUALLY.
JOE BIDEN WANTS RECOGNIZED THIS
TACTIC BECAUSE HE KNOWS
POLITICS.
HERE'S BIDEN IN 2006 IN A CLIP
WE WERE GRATEFUL TO GET
RECOGNIZING THAT COMPLAINING
ABOUT GAY MARRIAGE IS A PRETTY
HANDY WAY FOR POLITICIANS TO
DISTRACT.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN.
>> THE WORLD IS GOING TO HAITIS
IN A HAND BASKET.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCE RELATING TO AVIAN
FLU.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH VACCINES,
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH POLICE
OFFICERS.
WE'RE GOING TO DEBATE THE NEXT
THREE WEEKS I'M TOLD GAY
MARRIAGE, A FLAG AMENDMENT AND
GOD ONLY KNOWS WHAT ELSE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE THROUGH THIS.
WE ALREADY HAVE A LAW, THE
DEFENSIVE MARRIAGE ACT.
WE ALL VOTED.
MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN A MAN AND A
WOMAN AND STATES MUST RESPECT
THAT.
NOBODY HAS VIOLATED THAT LAW.
THERE'S BEEN NO CHALLENGE TO
THAT LAW.
WE DO WE NEED A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT?
MARRIAGE IS BETWEEN A MAN AND A
WOMAN.
>> Tucker: SO HE GETS A PASS
BECAUSE THAT WAS PREDEMENTIA.
HE HAS NO MEMORY OF IT.
THAT WAS AN INTERESTING INSIGHT.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT STUFF LIKE
THIS, PARTICULARLY WHEN IT'S NOT
SPEAKING RELEVANT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT OTHER
THINGS.
IT MAKES IT MORE INTERESTING
THAT JOE BIDEN'S HANDLERS 16
YEARS LATER ARE TELLING HIM TO
TALK ABOUT GAY MARRIAGE AND DRAG
SHOWS.
IT'S IN HIS BILL SIGNING TO
COMPLETELY PULL YOUR ATTENTION
AWAY FROM EVERYTHING ELSE GOING
ON, HE CAME OUT IN FAVOR OF GAY
MARRIAGE AND IT'S BEEN LEGAL FOR
TEN YEARS AND IN FAVOR OF THE
GENERAL MUTILATION OF CHILDREN.
HERE HE IS.
>> WE NEED TO CHALLENGE THE
HUNDREDS OF CALLOUS AND CYNICAL
LAWS INTRODUCED IN THE STATE
TARGETING TRANSGENDER CHILDREN,
TERRIFYING FAMILIES AND
CRIMINALIZING DOCTORS THAT GIVE
CHILDREN THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT THESE
CHILDREN SO THEY KNOW THEY'RE
LOVED AND WE WILL STAND UP FOR
THEM AND SAY THEY CAN SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> Tucker: IT'S INTERESTING WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
THIS IS A BILL SIGNING AFFIRMING
THE LEGALITY, LEGALIZING ONCE
AGAIN GAY MARRIAGE, WHICH MOST
PEOPLE SUPPORT IN THIS COUNTRY.
SHOULD PEOPLE GET MARRIED IF
THEY LOVE EACH OTHER?
THAT'S FINE.
IT'S NOT THAT CONTROVERSIAL A
POINT AT THIS STAGE.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN USING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE FOR KIDS.
THAT MEANS THE SEXUAL
MIGHTLATION OF CHILDREN.
CUTTING THE BREASTS OFF OF
15-YEAR-OLDS AND STERILIZING
CHILDREN WITH CHEMICALS.
PUBERTY BLOCKERS.
HAVE FUN WITH OSTEOPOROSIS WHEN
YOU'RE 30.
WHY WOULDN'T JOE BIDEN BE
PROMOTING THAT?
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
GAY MARRIAGE.
BUT HERE YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
PURPORTEDLY PUSHING CHILD SEXUAL
MUTILATION.
THEN YOU HAVE -- THIS IS
WEIRDER -- KAMALA HARRIS UP
THERE TALKING ABOUT
CONTRACEPTION.
REALLY?
WATCH.
>> FOR MILLIONS OF LGBTQI +
AMERICANS AND INTERRACIAL
COUPLES, THIS IS A VICTORY AND
IT IS PART OF A LARGER FIGHT.
THE DOBBS DECISION REMINDS US
THAT FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS ARE
INTERCONNECTED INCLUDING RIGHT
TO MARRY WHO YOU LOVE, THE RIGHT
TO ACCESS CONTRACEPTION AND THE
RIGHT TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
YOUR OWN BODY.
>> NOW WE'RE JUST CONFUSED.
THE RIGHT TO BYE CONTRACEPTION
NOW.
NOBODY ON THIS SHOW IS A LEGAL
SCHOLAR.
BUT GRISWOLD VERSUS CONNECTICUT
CAME DOWN IN 1967, WHICH
AFFIRMED FROM THE HIGH COURT THE
RIGHT OF AMERICANS TO BUY
CONTRACEPTION.
THAT WAS 56 YEARS AGO.
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE?
THAT'S BEEN LEGAL FOR OUR
LIFETIMES.
NO ONE IS TRYING TO MAKE IT
ILLEGAL.
NOT ONE PERSON IS PUSHING TO
MAKE THAT ILLEGAL.
NOT ONE.
SO HERE YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS AFFIRMING YOUR
RIGHT TO BUY THE PILL AND MARRY
SOMEONE OF A DIFFERENT RACE EVEN
THOUGH NEITHER RIGHT IS UNDER
ATTACK BY ANYONE.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
WELL, IT'S A PIECE OF THEIR
AGENDA.
THIS IS THE SAME PARTY THAT
PUSHED THROUGH AN ANTI LYNCHING
BILL THIS YEAR.
LINCHING.
ARE THERE LYNCHINGS GOING ON?
WAS IT ALREADY ILLEGAL?
NO.
WE JUST BANNED IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
WATCH.
>> THE SENATE SUCCEEDED IN
TAKING LONG OVERDUE ACTION
BYPASSING THE EMMITT TILL
ANTI-LYNCHING ACT.
HALLELUJAH.
CONGRESS HAS FINALLY DECLARED
LYNCHING A FEDERAL CRIME.
>> THE PEOPLE OF OUR NATION
DESERVE THE PROTECTION OF A
FEDERAL ANTI-LYNCHING LAW.
LYNCHING IS NOT A RELIC OF THE
PAST.
RACIAL ACTS OF TERROR STILL
OCCUR IN OUR NATION.
>> HATE WILL NOT PREVAIL IN
AMERICA.
WHITE SUPREMISTS WILL NOT HAVE
THE LAST WORD.
WE CANNOT REMAIN SILENCE.
SILENCE IS COMPLICITY.
FINALLY AFTER ALL OF THESE
YEARS, FINALLY MADE LYNCHING A
FEDERAL CRIME.
>> Tucker: AFTER ALL OF THESE
YEARS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE FOR
LYNCHING, BUT WE HELD OFF THE
PRO LYNCHING LOBBY AND WE GOT
THIS THROUGH THE CONGRESS.
WE'VE IMPROVED YOUR LIFE.
WHERE ARE ALL OF THESE LYNCHS,
THE RACIAL ACTS OF TERROR
COMMITTED BY WHITE SUPREMACISTS?
SEARCH THE INTERNET FOR THEM.
HARD TO FIND A LOT COMMITTED BY
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
ANY MAYBE.
WHAT ARE THE NUMBERS ON THAT?
HOW MANY RACIAL ATTACKS BY WHITE
SUPREMACISTS HAVE THERE BEEN IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS?
THERE'S BEEN A LOT.
WE'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
WE'RE NOT AWARE.
I'M PRETTY SURE IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
WE KNOW THAT NOOSES HAVE
APPEARED IN VARIOUS PLACES.
THERE WAS ONE AT THE
CONSTRUCTION SITE OF BARACK
OBAMA'S NEW PRESIDENTIAL
LIBRARY.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE AUGUST
THING ABOUT.
OFFERED A SIX FIGURE AWARD TO
FIND A PERSON THAT TIED ROPE IN
A FORBIDDEN SHAPE.
AND THEN THE NEWS IN THE NASCAR
GARAGE.
AND THE NOOSE AROUND JESSE
SMOLLETT'S NECK.
IS THAT THE ONE THEY'RE BAN
SOMETHING YOU KNOW THAT IS NOT
REAL.
MOST PEOPLE KNOW IT'S NOT REAL.
WHY ARE THEY CONTINUING TO SAY
THIS?
WELL, BECAUSE AS ACTUAL
PROBLEMS, REAL PROBLEMS MOUNT
AND THEY HAVE NO ANSWER AND NO
SOLUTION AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
DODGE CULPABILITY, THEY HAVE TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON FAKE PROPS.
WE'RE BANNING LYNCHING.
BILL MELUGIN AND HIS TEAM JUST
SHOT THIS NEW VIDEO OF MASSIVE
CROWDS OF FOREIGN NATIONALS
INVADING OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S TRUE.
MOST OF THEM ARE NOT FROM
MEXICO.
THEY'RE VERY FAR AWAY ACROSS THE
OCEANS AND NOW IN A MEXICAN
BORDER TOWN ACROSS FROM
BROWNSVILLE, TEXAS.
THEY'RE WAITING FOR TITLE 42 TO
END IN EIGHT DAYS.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WHEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DROPS THAT
LAST PIECE OF LEGAL DEFENSE
AGAINST INVASION, IT'S GOING TO
BE AN OVERWHELMING WAVE, OF
COURSE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
BRINGING DRAG STARS AND CINDI
LAUPER TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR FROM
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
APPEARING TO DASH HOPES OF A
DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION WARNS THE
WAR WILL BE LONG AND THAT THE
RISK OF A NUCLEAR CONFLICT IS ON
THE RISE.
HE QUICKLY DIALLED BACK HIS
LANGUAGE INSISTING RUSSIA WOULD
ONLY USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON FOR
SELF-DEFENSE, NEVER FIRST.
IT WAS MORE OF A REMINDER THAT
AN OVER THREAT.
THE RISK IS INCREASING HE SAID
ADDING THAT WE HAVEN'T GONE MAD.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ARE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WAVE IT LIKE
A RAZOR BLADE AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT OF COURSE, WE MUST PROCEED
FROM THE FACT THAT WE HAVE IT.
>> Tucker: SO WE'RE NOW AT WAR A
HOT WAR, WITH RUSSIA.
AMERICAN MILITARY PERSONNEL,
LOTS OF U.S. GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES ARE IN UKRAINE
FIGHTING THE WAR WITH WEAPONS
THAT YOU PAID FOR AND THE GUY
WE'RE AT WAR WITH THREATENED TO
USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AGAINST US.
THAT IS NOT A STORY?
THAT'S NOT BIGGER THAN BANNING
LYNCHING OR LEGALIZING GAY
MARRIAGE AGAIN WHEN IT WAS
ALREADY LEGAL?
WE'RE LEGALIZING CONTRACEPTION
THAT HAS BEEN AVAILABLE SI